[Musique]
l'archipel japonais' 20 ans dans
le futur
la saturation canine a atteint des
proportions épidémiques une épidémie de grippe canine a
ravagé la ville de La Mecque le
maire de saké Kobayashi émet des ordonnances d'urgence
appelant à une quarantaine précipitée l'
île des ordures devient une colonie exilée l'île
aux chiens  Je ne pense pas que je puisse supporter
plus de ces ordures que personne
n'abandonne ici et ne l'oublie
jamais ton Rex ton roi ton duc ton
patron Je suis le chef nous sommes une meute de
chiens alpha effrayants et indestructibles Atari
Kobayashi  vous avez héroïquement détourné un
turbopropulseur junior XJ 750 et l'avez volé vers
les îles à cause du chien
sacrément j'ai le béguin pour vous nous avons
l'idée que vous cherchiez vos
spots de chien perdu
est-ce que quelqu'un sait des étincelles s'il est vivant
peut très bien  vivre même en ce
moment en tant que prisonnier captif quelqu'un prépare
quelque chose allez-vous l'aider le
petit pilote pourquoi devrais-je parce que c'est un
garçon de 12 ans les chiens aiment ceux-là nous le
trouverons où qu'il soit s'il est un  en direct,
nous trouverons votre chien
où quelqu'un parlait sa langue
au nord une longue chaussée branlante
sur un marais de boues nocives menant à une
décharge radioactive polluée par des
déchets chimiques toxiques c'est notre destination
grazie - ciao